تغيير رئيس الوزراء في فرنسا
كان من المتوقع على نطاق واسع أن
تغادر إليزابيث بورن أه الصباح
بعد 20 شهرًا مضطربًا ولكن أه أصبح
أكثر صعوبة في النهاية بسبب
قانون الهجرة الذي اعتبره الكثيرون
مثيرًا للجدل للغاية وكانت هناك
شائعات بأنها قد تكون كذلك  حل محل H
واسم خليفتها غابرييل عتال
أصبح في الأيام القليلة الماضية أه
موضوع الكثير من التكهنات
غابرييل لال يصبح أصغر
رئيس وزراء فرنسي في تاريخ
الجمهورية الفرنسية لذلك منذ عام 1958 أيضا
أول مثلي الجنس علنا  كان من
المتوقع على نطاق واسع أن يكون هناك
تغيير وزاري من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى
رحيل إليزابيث بور التي
شغلت المنصب لمدة 20 شهرًا، لقد كان
وقتًا مضطربًا إلى حد ما بالنسبة لسياسي لتولي منصب رئيس الوزراء هنا في فرنسا.  لها كان هناك
إصلاح المعاشات التقاعدية أيضا
الاحتجاجات في الشوارع نتيجة
مقتل شاب من أصل جزائري عمره 17 سنة
على يد الشرطة وطبعا أه
خسارة ماكون
للأغلبية الرئاسية في البرلمان في
الانتخابات الأخيرة وحتى الآن  لقد نجت حتى
الآن، ومن المفهوم أن
قانون الهجرة الذي تم تقديمه في نهاية
العام الماضي هو الذي ربما وضعه في
أصعب الصعوبات، وعندما
بدأت الشائعات، قد يتم التضحية بها في النهاية
لصالح دولة جديدة.
بعد ذلك يتولى رئيس الوزراء غابرييل أتال مهام منصبه،
وهو يعتبر مثيرًا للجدل إلى حد ما
حتى داخل صفوف الحكومة، ويقال
إن ترشيحه تعرض للتأخير
نتيجة معارضة العديد من
أكبر المتضررين في الحكومة، وهو الآن
مستعد للإعلان عن حكومته الجديدة التي
تتطلع إلى الفترة المقبلة.  أشهر قليلة هي
فترة صعبة متوقعة كما يقول من
يتابعون السياسة الفرنسية عن كثب مع
الانتخابات الأوروبية التي من المرجح أن تكون بمثابة
اختبار للحكومة الفرنسية وأه
رئاسة إيمانويل ماكرون غابرييل
غابرييل أتال الآن يقود تلك الحكومة
إليها وبالطبع أبعد من ذلك
قرب نهاية  الولاية الثانية
لإيمانويل ماكرون ميليسا بيل سي إن إن باريس